I'm so excited to be standing here with
Arne Duncan the US Secretary of
Education great to see you thank you
what why are you talking to us I'm
honored I'm honored you play basketball
in Australia too right I did I got
caught wasn't good enough to play here
and they sent me the other side of the
world and had an amazing time played it
for four years you played in Australia
for four years and then they sent you to
I stopped playing I came back in and got
a real job went to work so you're you're
back like your fallback plan was the US
Secretary of Education far from it now
my passions have always been education
and basketball those were only two jobs
ever had so it's been an amazing busy
run like a class act I feel like would
enjoy a classy steak dinner together
are you married happily married married
my wife who's from Australia she's from
Australia dragged her back Trish Sarah
Caron analogy about what the US public
school system needs well we'll make some
real progress our graduation rates are
the highest has never been so slam-dunk
not a slam dunk but long way to go so
we're working progress but ain't aiming
the right way we're trying to win we're
trying to win here we're at least
shooting on the right who we are
shooting the right hoop and we want to
keep making baskets
we're not dunking in the wrong hoop no
thank goodness that would be bad that
would be very bad do you control school
lunches I don't and once we got some
work to do there right my friend Tom
Vilsack at the department bag works of
school lunches and Tom Vilsack yes does
he have any funny nicknames I'm not sure
you give one belsat do you have any
nicknames
I don't Arne Duncan I'll take slam
Duncan slam what did you deal man he's
got a gun I've been talking to NBA
players all day though some good guys
out here what's your karaoke song
seeking skills whatsoever that's the
best kind of karaoke person we're gonna
get you drunk tonight we're gonna sing
some journey
we got to teach kids bring art back to
the school throw with you but if I leave
it on pill art I got static away
President Obama is your boss he is my
boss could you beat him at one-on-one I
plead the fifth yeah do you hang out
with Obama we do what's he smell like
something good right no I do he's a heck
of a teammate I'm not saying like he has
a strong odor like he walks into a
Yankee Candle what I'm just like he's
probably got I'm not something pleasant
a few broken noses my smells not very
you are smooth like a Jim if you know
Conan you went to Harvard at the same
time as Cohen I didn't know him but
we're almost exactly the same age is
that right yeah yeah so I follow scurry
and he was obviously done fantastic I'm
a big fan I'm a big fan - he's my boss I
could definitely beat him at one-on-one
no doubt no doubt and Obama two-on-one
I'll take them both down take the first
one I know about the second you no bomb
against you - we'll try that one out to
be Secret Service guys giving me dirty
eyes and stuff it's not fair
don't let it fly the ladies play yeah
look if you can make that happen there
we're on basic cable we need ratings
boost the dunk slam dunk kill it okay
you're killing it in life please please
don't change it's like I'm signing your
yearbook don't change